i mean when i was competing it was
necessary
but it makes me remember i didn't really
remember what uh
what i used to be like until that it's
like
when i'm working out seven hours a day
yeah and just
so obsessed and and all i was thinking
about was winning
that's all i was thinking about like if
they were if they were working out five
hours a day i wanted
i wanted them to know that i was gonna
work out an extra three hours
and i was gonna get up early and i was
gonna text them all hey [ __ ]
i'm up already take pictures send
selfies you know i was like
you're gonna die oh i kept telling them
you're all gonna die you try to keep up
with me you're gonna die
you weren't fully joking no i wasn't
joking at all
that's what i was [ __ ] up about it was
the scary thing when i interact with
goggins and what i saw in you
on during that time is like
this guy like like this is why i've been
avoiding david ganga's recently
[Laughter]
is like because he wants to meet he has
to do like talk on this podcast but he
also wants to run an
ultra marathon with me and i felt like
this is a person
if i spend any time in this realm if i
spend any time with the joe rogan of
that
sober october like i might have to die
to get out
like there's this kind of uh yeah
there's a competitive aspect that's
super unhealthy
i mean you saw the video that we watched
earlier today of goggins draining his
knee
that would stop me from running ever
again because i would think in my head
okay
i'm going to ruin my cartilage i'm going
to need a knee replacement i would start
thinking i would
go down that line but he is perpetually
in this push-it mindset you know what he
calls the dog in him you know he's got
that dog is in him all day long and he
feeds that dog
you know and that's um that's who he is
that's one of the reasons why he's so
inspirational and he's
fuel for millions and millions of people
i mean he really is he motivates people
in a way that is
it's so powerful but it can be very
destructive
i just i know i know now especially
after the sober october thing that that
thing's still in me
you know i didn't know so really haven't
done anything physically competitive
except one time i was supposed to fight
wesley snipes it came out then too
that came out too that got creepy too
but luckily that never happened
but that was many months of training
like
training twice a day every day
kickboxing in the morning
jiu-jitsu at night i was just going
going and going and going
and i was just thinking just all day
long and it but
it [ __ ] with all the other aspects of
your life [ __ ] with your friendships
[ __ ] with your your [ __ ] with my comedy
[ __ ] with everything
because that mindset is not a mindset of
an artist
it's a mindset of a conqueror
you